mit einem einzigen command ich finde so
kresse wohl einfach komplett zu
bulgarien zugefügt
herzlich willkommen hier zu einer folge
der minecraft dabei gesagt dienstags
kommen immer commands wo ich nur ein
komfort stelle der zu lang wäre für die
folgen sich also ein command der mehrere
dinge hinzufügen beispielsweise nicht
nur einen kothaufen sondern zwei
kothaufen und dazu noch einen keks und
dann kann man sich noch haustiere machen
und dazu kann man das
nee mal den ganzen schwachsinn beiseite
eigentlich sollte gestern auch ein video
kommen allerdings darf sie sich youtube
dass das kommt halten
deswegen werde ich schauen ob ich das
dann irgendwie morgen oder übermorgen
oder so veröffentlichen kann allerdings
kommen jetzt heute erstmal der command
ich würde mich freuen wenn wir bis zum
ende dran wetter macht ist ihr bewertet
wenn ihr mehr davon wollten einen kanal
abonniert dich hab gerade gefrühstückt
habe mir hier selbstverständlich schon
einen command blog geholt über den
befehl / gfp command unterschied block
und einen redstone block und ich bin in
einer wunderschönen welt wo alles voll
mit ton ist und so finde ich ja immer
ist eine mit der schönsten biome setze
ich mir einfach hin füge diesen command
eines hucal wieder ganz kurz und wir
sehen schon die verkommenen eingefügt
und wir sehen schon da mario level es
ist nämlich ein mario commerce und zwar
setzt man den rats am block neben und
ihr seht schon das ganze baut sich hoch
und wir bekommen genau jetzt die
maschine fertig und ich meine auf dieser
seite
ja genau auf dieser seite ihr seht schon
hier von der engineer der hat sich drauf
da müsst ihr auf jeden fall mal
vorbeischauen geht hier auch nochmal
command mario mechanik spread engineer
get things right click vista alten
remove ich krieg natürlich erstmal auf
geld allerdings pack ich vorher diese
beiden sachen hier erst mal kurz raus
ihr seht schon ich habe hier schon so
ein paar effekte und ich habe auch schon
so ne mario uniformen einfach weil es
gerade schon getestet habe aber ich
klicke erstmal auf geld und dann seht
ihr schon bekomme ich genau neuen items
die das ganze hier möglich machen und
zwar erkläre ich euch jetzt mal diese
items ganz einfach nach der reihe
nachdem ich hier aber erstmal einmal was
habe ich gerade überhaupt vor damit wir
hier ein bisschen mehr mario stimmung
haben habe ich jetzt hier so ein
bisschen frisches gras einfach
hingesetzt aber wir fangen jetzt mal mit
der bedeutet von den items und zwar
bekommen wir die items briggs lucky
block und einen mushroom lacken blogger
sie die boxen auch dann vertreten dann
einen boom bei directions witcher der
die maas nord süd und kompass westen
osten lenkt also quasi als begrenzung
gilt dann kein fleck und level starter
ich habe mir natürlich informieren
wir nehmen nämlich erstmal den level
start- und platzieren den studierenden
beispielsweise und zwar jetzt jede
person die hier drüber läuft wird
automatisch zu mario das heißt wenn ich
hier drauf geht wenig mario das bin ich
jetzt gerade schon hier seht schon ich
hab sogar noch meinen ein cape dahinten
von opti faymann also ausgehen wird
quasi einfach verwandelt in mario
das heißt wenn ich jetzt hier
beispielsweise auch meinen kopf abnehmen
oder so da passiert nichts weil ich
einfach mit mario verwandelt haben etwa
ihr seht doch schon hier meine effekt
ich habe extra energie sättigung dass
ich nicht wenn ich sprinter oder so
einfach hunger kriege und sprungkraft
das geht ganz einfach daran wenn ich
einmal aufspringen drücke springe ich
halt höher als normal
einfach um blöcke hoch zu kommen und so
weiter und so fort also das macht
einfach dieser level starter den
platziert ihr einfach am anfang wenn man
darüber läuft wird man halt direkt zu
mario fleck ist das ganze gegenteil von
von dem starter ding und zwar plötzlich
die flagge einfach mal hierhin wie zeige
ich euch mal am ende
das ist mir nicht ganz einfach ein
williger der der stirbt da oben sehen
jetzt diese flagge und wenn ich danach
er hinlaufen zeige ich euch ganz am ende
da wird das ganze zu einer grünen flagge
und das heißt dann the way das level
geschafft lasse dann kommt jetzt mal zu
den ganz einfachen sachen und zwar den
brics die können eigentlich nichts außer
kaputt gehen
ich platze jetzt erstmal hier oben ein
paar als ich mache das ganze jetzt mal
einfach so damit ich euch das gleich
zeigen kann
das sind einfach die brics da kann ich
weiter die sprung verstärkung hat ganz
easy drauf springen und das sind einfach
briggs wenn ich jetzt hier langlauf und
beispielsweise hier mal gegen springe
oder so dann seht ihr schon die teile
gehen kaputt weil ihr kennt
wahrscheinlich von mario springen
dagegen briggs die gehen einfach kaputt
wenn man dagegen springt so am besten
packt man die auch drei hoch damit man
dafür auch ein bisschen hoch springen
muss zloty gehen dann einfach kaputt
wenn ich da von unten gegen springe die
sind halt einfach nur so zur dekoration
so ein bisschen sind halt einfach so
brix von mario die kennt halt jeder dann
kein lack teamblog den platz sich jetzt
beispielsweise mal hier zwei stück das
sterben so ein paar o2 und der mushroom
lucky blog plötzlich einfach mal hier
hin
so und jetzt zeige ich erst mal den
macho lucky block und zwar spiele ich da
oben gegen machen kaputt und ihr seht
schon da kommt man schon raus und der
läuft vorneweg und da muss ich dann
irgendwie wieder einfangen und der
bleibt ist beispielsweise mal
hoffentlich genau hier bleibt stehen ihr
seht schon hier sind überall so komische
bunte teile gespannt und ich habe jetzt
quasi mehr macht bekommen das heißt wenn
ich jetzt beispiel ich bin jetzt ein
großer mario und wenn ich jetzt
beispielsweise mal hier komm ich da oben
überhaupt darauf ja genau wenn ich oben
drauf springen und ich beispielsweise
hochspringer und dabei nach unten gucke
dann knallte ich direkt wieder nach
unten und macht damit quasi den block
kaputt das kann eventuell einige aus den
neuen mario teilen wo man einfach hoch
springen kann cook nach unten und man
hat
nicht kaputt gemacht beim sorgt jetzt
hats geklappt also ist halt einfach nur
mario mit einem koma deswegen kann man
da auch nicht so viel erwarten
das heißt ich bin jetzt dadurch quasi
der große marke wahr geworden durch
diesen pilz den ich da eingesammelt habe
ach komm wir sammeln noch im feld seiner
mitglieder zählt läuft sonst da kommen
dann diese komischen blogger bläschen
und was macht einen lucky blog ja was
wohl ich bringe gegen und bekomme einen
coin und zwar seht ihr dann bekomme ich
halt diese käufe sind halt einfach diese
minecraft wollten da gibt es die coins
genannt wurden und er kann die dann halt
sammeln genau das gleiche brauche ich
aber nicht nur schmeißt man die sachen
weg die ich euch schon gezeigt hat uns
fabrik habe ich euch schon gezeigt
vollen lucky blog schon masche macchi
block level starter und lange und jetzt
es gibt doch diese ganz normalen conti
kann nicht einfach so hin setzen
beispielsweise sammle ich ein und dann
bekomme ich hier in den träumen
allerdings wenn ich jetzt mal das
default in rein packe sind schon da sie
nicht schon eindeutig mehr aus wie einst
und jetzt kann ich die beispielsweise
einsammeln geben und davon kann ich auch
ganz viele auf einem blog post um das
heißt wenn ich jetzt einen hinsetzen
kann ich auch hier geht auf den rand des
stockes draufklicken oder beispielsweise
hierhin oder da vorne oder so dann habe
ich da ganz viel und ich habe gerade 23
lauf da nochmal drüber und dann habe ich
jetzt 46 beispielsweise also ich kann
die auch alle übereinander drauf bin und
ich würd sagen wir packen jetzt mal eben
des zwecks text ein
weil das damit doch alles ein bisschen
schöner aus arbeit also das ist halt
dieses köln legen könnt ihr einfach
hinsetzen sammelt man ein und man hat
dadurch dann quasi einen köln habe ich
die ganze kaka eingesammelten wir jetzt
zu den sachen ohne die mario einfach
nicht mario wer da wäre es einfach viel
zu idee und zwar habe ich hier den kumba
direction switcher das heißt platz jeder
von jetzt beispielsweise mal hier ein
einfach unter der erde kann darüber noch
einen gebranntem ton platzieren und dann
beispielsweise auch noch hier vorne
hinein unter der erde und darüber ein
gebranntem ton und dann seht ihr jetzt
schon wenn ich mal auf drei drücke ich
rede da oben facing süden wenn ich
hierhin schaumfestiger besten norden
also da habe ich eingesetzt im norden
und dem süden das heißt sie muss jetzt
den kuba nehmen nord süden dem platz ihr
film madame ich habe darauf platziert
aber dem platz ich jetzt hier in game
mode survival dingsbums ob also ich sags
euch nochmal ich nehme hier jetzt
beispielsweise einfach einen
rumba nord süden bräuchte ich dafür der
ist hier glaube ich ja genau und ich
weiß nicht mehr genau ich glaube ich
hier war das ne ne was nicht was hier ja
genau hier und farbiger davon bin ich am
arsch so freundin machen das ganz locker
nochmal also wenn man sie sieht
damit ihr das aussehen wir setzen hier
einen boom bei directions witcher hin
und hier beispielsweise wenn ich jetzt
dazwischen das ist ja immer noch nord
süden
dazwischen einsätze dann müsste der
genau was soll denn das so hier habe ich
einen gebranntem ton drüber gepackt und
hier auch und ich setze mich in den
westen und wenn ich jetzt dinge hin
setzte jetzt klappt es lag wohl echt an
diesem ort süden dinge an die neuen
teile funktionieren wo liegen nicht bei
mir besten osten also so muss das ganze
dann aussehen und dann bleibt er quasi
die ganze dazwischen und da ich hätte
gerne ein
wie kann damit er trotzdem was tun
okay das ist total crazy der kam er
trotzdem weh tun obwohl ich in dem dings
bin im game und 1 okay nice nehmen wir
einfach so hin ich habe jetzt einfach
mal die items hier eben noch mal und
zwar was hatte ich euch denn noch nicht
gezeigt ich glaube dass das was waren
seine ganzen als jedes habe ich euch
alles gezeigt hier ganzen stiefel den
ganzen stetig an
das war es eigentlich einzige was jetzt
noch gibt es diese flagge und zwar wenn
ich dagegen laufen seht ihr schon da
oben sieht grün
du hast es geschafft super mario das ist
dann quasi schon der ganze roman kienast
schon der ganze das war schon recht viel
drin und zwar wurde hier einfach mit
einem mit einem einzigen command ich
finde so krasser wird einfach komplett
super-mario zugefügten zu euch gefallen
hat würde ich mich sehr über eine
bewertung freuen schaut auf jeden fall
bei die red engine ii vorbei das ist der
vater von diesem command und wenn ihr
mehr bock auf solche vorstellungen habt
würde ich mich über einen subscribe
allerdings von euch freuen alle links
zum command wie man das ganze macht wie
da bleiben
beschreibung ca